Seymour Hersh award-winning author why
did the Russian shoot down Korean
Airlines flight double-oh-seven they
made a bad mistake they thought it was
an American military plane they did not
know it was a passenger airliner the
American people have been told or were
told at the time that the Russians did
identify that as a civilian airliner or
they could not mistake it for a civilian
airliner but you disagree more
categorically than that they were told
that that our intelligence had shown
that the Russians had identified it as
an airliner before shooting it down at
that time that was a statement made by
Secretary of State George Shultz 20
hours after the shoot down at that time
the community had come to almost the
opposite conclusion they concluded the
Russians did not know there was an
inevitable follow-up in the first few
hours after the crisis that happens in
any crisis the wrong information never
you know the right information ever gets
where it should but I really think and a
focal point of what I've written about
in the book is the fact that beginning
with day two of the crisis through today
the administration has absolutely closed
the books on it and absolutely confirmed
every intelligence agency the NSA the
CIA the DIA defense intelligence agency
every American intelligence agency has
concluded that the Russians did not
identify that plane and we've never
corrected the record this morning we'll
be discussing a really tragic incident
on September 1st 1983 the Soviets shot
down KL flight double-oh-seven
269 passengers and crew were killed how
it happened is detailed in a new book by
Seymour Hersh it's called the target is
destroyed what really happened to flight
double-oh-seven and what America knew
about it it's published by Random House
and I believe that came out this week
right published Monday our guest is its
author Seymour Hersh former reporter
with the New York Times and you also did
the Kissinger story the price of power
Jamis I enjoyed the shooting down a
flight double-oh-seven is our subject
this morning we'll be taking calls in
just a few moments in fact we have some
in already the numbers will be listed
throughout the show at the bottom of
your screen first of all you received
help from the Russians in writing this
book I wouldn't say help I received
permission to go to Russia
which was unusual and interview some of
their top officials early on this is in
1984 when I first began the book before
I really knew very much about it
I went to the Soviet embassy and asked
for permission to go there an interview
find out for myself since the Russians
were claiming that Ronald Reagan had
sent the plane that it was a spy plane
which I didn't find credible which
everybody in the government had course
categorically denied and don't forget
there was a lot of suspicion and it
probably still is no matter how many
books you write or what kind of
categorical evidence of empirical
evidence you produce there's a lot of
people who want to believe that you know
that this was really some sort of secret
intelligence operation that KL was
really a flight as an intelligence
flight so I thought I'd just see if the
Russians had anything that they were
willing to share with me privately
perhaps that they didn't want to talk
about publicly after a few months delay
they gave me a visa I paid my own way
let me make it clear and I went over and
I saw the chief marshal of the Soviet
Union
Nikolay ogar cough he was the man who
about a week after the incident I tried
to explain to the world what happened
sort of an unprecedented news conference
a live news conference in Moscow and I
also saw Nikolay Georgi Kornienko was
his name at Deputy Foreign Minister sort
of the leading man in the foot in the
Soviet foreign ministry on American
affairs and I think the only way to
describe what happened is I basically
got stiffed over there I went over there
and they invited me and they really had
very little the critical moment came
when in a long interview after days of
seeing lesser officials and being given
pretty much a routine story I finally
saw the top people and ogar cough and
Kornienko had nothing and I asked them
at one point I guess as I would with an
American general I say hey come here I'm
here I've been here for ten days in this
country I haven't given me any evidence
at all do you have any and they said
well that's why we invited you here you
know comrade Hersh we thought you know
you've written about the CIA before
maybe you'd be able to find that the CIA
did this and basically I described all
of this and about a page and a half in
the book that's the extent of it but it
was interesting being there because I
think I honestly think that at one level
those guys believe I really want to
believe that Ronald
insensibly our first calls from Delray
Beach Florida
go ahead I'd like to ask you about
something that's bothered me greatly
yeah about the cruise use of the
airborne radar with its terrain mapping
function I saw you on the Donahue show
the other day and it point came up and I
believe like I understood you to say
that the crew might have used it looked
at it and dismissed it and I just find
that hard to believe based both on
personal experience and what I know of
other airline crews habits on these in
these battery for example that route
lends itself beautifully to the at least
the intermittent use of the mapping
function and surely they would know when
they looked at it but they couldn't
dismiss the difference between being
over say a small island like Bering
island earth on that root and the
Kamchatka Peninsula for example through
the round in the flight to have a whole
series of island change the Kuril
Islands so forth that show up very
distinctively on on that type of mapping
and I haven't flown the route I don't
have general experience from that but I
have offshore experience the similar
routes that believe me it's frequently
while it's not it's not the part of the
operation as sergeants frequently the
habit of airline crews to do precisely
that to use the mapping function of the
radar and they were not almost instantly
if they were off course you could be you
couldn't be more correct I mean it's
it's it's inconceivable that they did
not check the only thing we can say is
this that they were off course 365 miles
there's absolutely no evidence that they
were where they were off course early on
in the flight they had a number you
sound like you're a pilot obviously they
had a number of chances to verify their
flight path they apparently chose not to
there was some without getting into the
technology there were some electronic
beams vor that they could have they
could have independently assessed their
position with once they got over the
ocean
it's to the average pilot the average
American pilot particularly somebody
flew in the military it's inconceivable
they weren't looking at their ground
mapping radar that that's a device in
the copic that gives you the ability
they use it to fly around bad weather
basically if you have a bad storm path
coming you can get around it how does a
guy not look at it well all we're trying
to do and what I'm what I'm describing
is is only what only the we'll never
know what happened to the plane except
to say I can say categorically that
there's no evidence in talking to
American intelligence officials who had
with whom I had enormous access and were
very straight to me about how
disappointed they were with the way the
White House manipulated the intelligence
I mean they took took a lot of guts to
say this
none of the men I talked to were very
critical of the way the intelligence was
handled said they had any advance notice
of the plane being there which they
would have had to have had if it was a
spy plane no sense sending a spy plane
if you're not gonna be there to reap the
fruits you know of activating radar etc
so it wasn't a spy plane and all I can
tell you is that a couple of the very
best people in the National
Transportation Safety Board and the FAA
accident investigation group went over
there and I can't quote him by name
because they did a private investigation
they came out terribly skeptical of the
way korean airlines was running its shop
there was a lot of problems there those
guys were lining up their RNs is wrong
they weren't paying any attention to
what was going on in the cockpit in
their opinion and the only way you can
the one of the thesis is one of the
things you can say is pilots have told
me and I have talked to pilots to admit
this some of the pilots who do a lot of
travel back and forth that often ground
mapping radar is not that dependable it
will sometimes go walk it'll walk out on
you and often if it shows something you
don't want it to show you will decide
it's not correct that's all I can say we
don't really know what happened your
points well-taken one of the things you
bring out in the book is that the
cockpit operation is so computerized and
can be put on automatic pilot that the
crews sometimes you claim don't pay that
much attention to it
well airline trainers I talked to some
of the vice-president for training of
some of the major American air
and they tell me one of the biggest
problems they have now is convincing
pilots not to fly by rote not to get in
there and do everything automatically
and some of you might remember some of
the people might be old enough to
remember when automatic pilots first
came on about 25 years ago Bob Newhart
the comedian had this wonderful bit
where he the pilot would get gotten the
copic that announced explained that an
automatic pilot and said nothing can go
wrong nothing can go wrong nothing can
go wrong this is sort of an advanced leg
on that we've gone way up now everything
is computerized and the important thing
to know about how they how the system
works is this that because of NASA and
the Space Age we have developed
incredible inertial it's called the
inertial navigation system it's a
navigation system ILS you refer to
earlier right it it gives you everything
you need to know inside your own plane
you don't have to take an external fix
you don't have to look at the Stars of
the Moon decide where you are and pilots
previously had to do this particularly
when flying over places like the North
Pole where there was a lot of magnetic
disturbance now this thing it measures
something known as the earth rate
precession whatever that is some measure
of the earth has it revolves around its
axis and its path its daily path around
them around the Sun I guess and anyway
by measuring this it can tell you where
you are at any time internally so you
never can get lost all you have to do is
get into the cockpit put in the in in
the computer for the ILS put in the data
where you are and where you want to go
press the automatic pilot and do
whatever you want to do take a nap deal
cards but in the book you mentioned that
perhaps the wrong codes report in it
make a one-digit mistake and you can be
all considered a bit is that the group's
investigating this the International
Civil Aviation Organization ICAO which
is the UN group that monitors our
airline commercial airline activity out
of Montreal and that agency and the
American intelligence community
particularly the air force which study
this incident very well very carefully
all concluded that's what he did he put
the wrong number they call it finger
trouble and in Korean Airlines it turns
out it happens a lot it happened three
times the Korean airline airline
different flights in the year before KL
went down those guys are coming to the
cockpit instead of getting there a half
hour earlier and warming it up and
checking it out they
we're coming in heavy late punching in
the numbers probably they may even be
punching in the numbers as they were
taxing which happens often and what that
does is it destroys any means for the
ANS to give warnings you know once you
start moving and beginning to do things
the NS can't can't warn you that you're
putting in the wrong information it's
there's a lot of ways it could have
happened but I have to emphasize as the
caller made the point that in any single
one of these possibilities you can raise
questions about it how could they not
have done this the only thing I can say
is we if we ever learned everything they
did to get to 365 miles off course in
the middle of the Soviet Union we
probably never flying in Portland Oregon
you're next I was oh one five morning
update in Anchorage and
we've been forced through that same
route and I think we left and I believe
it's about 20 minutes after
double-oh-seven left and I recall seeing
the flight crew get on and and the whole
group of people there was just amazing -
we had noticed the group of people
getting on the plane and how they were
all walking together the pilots all the
big sister Issus and laughing and
giggling that was really where they
became quite they had afterwards but
anyway I have a couple questions first
of all far was oh one five away from
Joseph 10 to 20 minutes behind him on he
flew the same route as you may know you
probably do know you probably studied it
quite a bit there are five basic routes
between Anchorage Alaska and Seoul and
the Far East Japan and South Korea the
one the one furthest north closest to
the Soviet unit is known as our twenty
it's the most desirable track apparently
because apparently the prevailing winds
are either lighter or greater whatever
one they whatever they have to be to
make the flight easier and everybody
wants our twenty flight 0:07
flew our twenty about anywhere from ten
to fifteen minutes ahead of flight oh
one five your flight and you originated
in Los Angeles correct right go ahead I
have never talked anybody from that's
like keep on what's your anchor ijen I
know if they arrived approximately the
same time as we did and our planes were
sitting right next to each other and in
fact it was interesting cuz I was
noticing that our flight was really full
and they were going to Seoul and I took
a look at the doorway there and I
thought I wonder how slow that plane is
and flip I thought well maybe we better
not try to give him this even if it
wasn't effectiveness did you really
think about that did you really think of
jumping planes shooting actually I fly
quite a bit and so it didn't bother me
and but I knew that my wife would not be
too happy
I did dig that pizza anyway thank
goodness we didn't but I have it but
about how many miles you were we were we
on that same our 20 yes
and so therefore we were probably within
what 250 miles of 300 well you you
should have been flying about 10 minutes
behind I think which would have been
about what 80 90 miles behind they fire
those planes airliners fly about eight
nine miles per minute what happened of
course is you deviated I mean you did
not deviate if flight o7 began deviating
and ironically one of the other
conspiracy theories is that somehow what
happened is as the flaw as flight o7
began to go farther north some of its
messages they could they could not get
through some of their normal messages
that we've normal reports you have to
report every hour every hour and a half
or so back to Anchorage and also then
the Tokyo they couldn't raise Anchorage
and so they called their sister flight
or one five and relayed through them
this happens a lot because there's often
a lot of atmospheric disturbance one
reason we now think obviously they
couldn't raise Anchorage's they were
drifting out a radio range going farther
north but nobody knew it it wasn't so
unusual to be relaying through oh one
five and apparently and I was surprised
to learn this there isn't that kind of
sophisticated radar aboard these
airliners that would have enabled oh one
oh one five to realize that the plane it
was talking to oh oh seven was far it
was much farther way than it should have
been they had no way of fixing it on a
radar they just didn't have that the
only radars these commercial airliners
have give you eight to ten miles around
you except for the loop down the ground
mapping radar which looks down and
doesn't isn't isn't set up to identify
other planes it just gives you the
bottom terrain so they spent the night
talking oh we know that the the pilot of
oh one five talked to the pilot the crew
of all oh seven eight to ten times
before oh seven was shot down and
there's one interesting thing that that
the officials of the ICAO the
International Civil Aviation
Organization told me which they did not
put in their report by the way and that
is that the pilot of old 15 said the
whole time he was
talking 2:07 he never talked to the
captain which led the ICAO officials to
conclude that the captain was out of the
cockpit through much of the flight and
what happened is in the back in the
first-class section of au 107 there were
six fellow Korean airline crew members a
couple of captain's some flight
lieutenants flying deadheading they call
it flying back for a reassignment and he
probably spent most of the flight
chatting with them and that may have had
a great impact on what happened in the
cockpit congressman Larry McDonald was
also in that first-class section
correct right he was the only passenger
of paying passenger in that section and
his staff tells me that he tended to do
as much a lot of sleeping's a hard
sleeper in fact he met when the planes
landed at Anchorage there was a lot of
milling in the lounge a transit lounge
which ironically that area is the
largest shopping center in all of
Anchorage at the airport so people tend
the mill around there and shop and do
things and McDonald never showed up
because his so his staff thinks he
probably was snoozing away and by the
way there were a lot of people who
thought in the McDonald supporters that
the Russians had shot down the plane
simply to get Larry McDonald out of the
way because he was such a bitter enemy
of communism now you mentioned in the
book that it is not unusual for a the
captain of a Korean Airlines plane to go
back and greet the first-class
passengers I would think that's part of
his job at some point no not necessarily
normal first-class passengers in this
case there were a group of McDonald and
other dignitaries dignitaries there were
group and the fellow from Portland's
flight there were Jesse Helms senator
Helms and another senator I think Simms
of of Idaho and a few congressmen also
along they were all going to South Korea
for ceremonies commemorating the 30th
anniversary of the of one of the u.s.
South Korea mutual defense agreements
and sort of a hawks Hawks the light
there and it would have been natural for
him to would go back and say hello to
McDonald even wake him up perhaps to say
hello but that was a long time you're
talking about many hours he wasn't there
the pilot of oh one five said he would
have chatted you know they chatted
during the night about whatever pilots
do by the way there's no recordings of
these conversations these are just plane
to plane they talked about said oh one
five
they talked about where they ate in
Anchorage and what they're gonna do when
they get into Seoul how boring it is and
you know the one thing that's
interesting sort of funny just the
position of words but it is interesting
sort of fascinating how boring it is it
turns out flying these airliners with
this new equipment this new stuff takes
all of the fun out of it it's just not
much fun anymore it's a job and what you
go and sit down and he mentioned Donahue
on the Donnie who showed one of the
caller calling people was a stewardess
who complained bitterly about all the
sleeping that goes on and transoceanic
fights so they sleep all the time and
she's reported to the FAA nobody cares
hey I've heard the same thing Canton
Illinois you're next
I'm a spiritual reputation preceded to
so I approached this question of the
greatest of respect I haven't had a
chance to read your book yet but I do
got to tell you on a major portion I
believe of the Donahue show the other
day and there was one little things that
seem to be omitted at least the portion
I heard that there's a bit bothersome no
doubt you went into this in detail in
your book or even discussed another
comment Jones but you seem to neglect
the presence of that routine
intelligence fly for some I repeat in
flight the proceeded as though oh seven
incident I forget the designation RG
something lugar ball sent the one you're
talking about a big very goober ball was
the name of the flight there's a plane
type I guess I was thinking yeah it's
going rc-135 right the one well if that
element of intelligence US intelligence
was so involved in dragging so forth in
connection without the machine as I my
routines bright early flight I believe
on the Donahue show you dismiss the fact
that the communications problem at
develop following this was a lack of
coordination lack of intelligence
certain line doesn't it seem that those
important elements US intelligence would
be greatly informed on radar recovery
because that general area both during
the
my intelligence right and following to
see what intercept the measures were
taken there seems to be a funding
knocking layer that yes the radar I
should have been more charges this
communication let me say first of all
something just generally about radar
radar only goes as far as the horizon
you know as far as the American radar
could see would be 200 miles from
wherever the radar facility is and there
were no rate there was no American radar
close enough to actually get a picture a
radar picture with blips on it of this
of the of the American plane
intelligence plane intersecting with the
Korean airliner which did happen
we do however monitor the Soviet radars
carefully and we are able to recreate
basically what the Soviet radar showed
we can't recreate their radar but we
could recreate electronically what they
should be tracking but and your question
is a good one
here's an American intelligence plane is
known as Cobra ball that's up there and
the that one of the basic points that
that that has to be made about this
incident this was the irony here's an
airlift for 25 years we've had American
intelligence planes operating off the
coast of the Soviet Union rc-135 there's
707 Boeing 707s the precursor of the 747
for engine jets and what they there's
two different kinds of mission there's a
mission known as River joint which flies
up the coast about 30 miles off off off
the land outside of in international
waters or air and monitors
communications that's loaded with
communication gear the kind of stuff
that would have been able to pick up
everything about this would have been
able to reproduce the Soviet radar would
have had its own radar and all the
signals there's another mission it
operates out of schemey Ireland in the
American held Aleutians about 450 miles
from Kamchatka it's the sort of the
easternmost post post of the United
States and this plane is known as Cobra
ball it goes up and it's got a
capability to lawyer in the air off the
Soviet Union about as long as 18 hours
with refueling and its mission is to
track the Soviet missiles when they are
fired in central to the central plains
of Soviet Union they are fired up they
go into outer space they impact in this
portion of the Far East
Camp chat
Vanessa where the incident took place
where the first meeting took place cobra
balls function is to they have special
cameras that film the the the missiles
as they enter that one of the things we
try and do is watch to see whether one
missile my mother missile has as many as
12 or 13 warheads separately targeted
and we monitor that their whole system
is designed for one thing photographing
and copying missiles they had absolutely
very little other intelligence
capability they do have one man whose
job is to try and monitor the comms they
call it to communication frequencies to
make sure that no Russian planes coming
after them that that's never happened by
the way in 25 years the Russians have
never attacked one of these planes you
know we we operate improve Li and they
leave us alone so they didn't have an
ability although a lot of people thought
they should have or did they simply had
no ability to have any sort of
intelligence collection except for what
they were designed for copying missiles
so they were flying pretty dumb and what
happens is a ho seven coming into Soviet
territory and a place where no airliner
is coming in 25 years
hits Soviet radar covers 200 miles out
so bees begin tracking it just as they
began coming into Soviet radar coverage
cobra ball which had been up looking for
a test that did not take place decides
to leave and Cobra ball pulls out a
Soviet radio coverage at that time so it
looks like it's either replacement plane
or its Cobra ball coming back cobra ball
flies big figure Eight's in and out of
radar coverage it's a bad coincidence
but the Soviets make it right away for a
military American military plane and the
Cobra ball plane has absolutely no idea
what's going on he goes home and he
parks they call him that my Ryan did I
do write about this in the book
obviously they call him that right away
that as soon as the plane is shot down
and these guys in the plane had no idea
anything had taken place
Lake Arrowhead in California you're next
[Applause]
I just happen to be a student of the
conspiracy theory he's about as a hobby
so you know I kind of follow things like
this you made an interesting point that
fits in with the theory of construe
that seemed to highlight the idea that
the the plane had the sophisticated
equipment to fly on its own and that one
idea is that the pilot bailed out and
the plane flew on its own and the
mission of the plane was to stop the
propaganda that was being propagated by
McDonald that the CIA and the KGB work
together and have been working together
for years and the way they got rid of
the man was to set up this
double-oh-seven and they work together
on it pilot you know was going on he
bailed out
I just betcha still one less is one
theory I don't know a lot over the over
the Pacific Ocean party North Pacific
who rescued him oh it's hard to say if
the plane that the point I was making
was that the plane can fly on its own is
that is that true I was wondering
whether that was actually true I'm not a
pilot yeah is it true that the plane oh
sure
Oh categorically the problem is though
that you do have to report into aviation
civil you have to report into the faa
into tokyo air traffic perfect if we get
around it all those things can be solved
but flying the plane is the main thing
yeah well you know look I mean I please
don't think I'm being unduly
a snotty here but anything's possible
which is what do you have evidence for
right there's absolutely not probably
evidence would be a plank of fly out of
thumb that's the other point I was
trying to make here that possible I
don't know let me ask you a question do
you really think we're here this country
though do you really think we're at this
stage let me answer this question do you
really think we're at this stage where
where somebody would authorize the
deaths of 269 people let's take away
once again we fight wars that kill
millions of people let's face it so you
know the CIA and KGB both are not that
the best people in the world they're
cloak and dagger people oh it's hard for
me to believe that they're yeah all
right sorry
anybody to believe but those things do
go on let's
we live in a very cruel world but
somebody would put 269 people at stake
Tony a very cruel thing to do that
person imagine cruel I mean that's a
worse thing cruel I mean you know that's
greater yeah I don't I can't even
imagine I'm just making one little point
here is that all right Oh listen any
theory exists and you know I would be I
could tell you you're wrong I can't even
tell you're wrong we'll never know
because nobody was in the copic all we
can do is make the best judgment we can
make based on the evidence and the best
judgment we can make based on the
evidence the one that makes the most
sense the one that has a certain the
word is ineluctable logic about it is
that they screwed up and they were off
course and they never knew it and even
when they got hit there's the evidences
they didn't know what hit him the first
their first message after they got hit
they they they didn't scream Mayday
Mayday I've been at bombed you know I've
been attacked by missile they said I'm
suffering rapid decompression going down
to 10,000 which is the level you go down
to we don't need air moxa Jim as for the
passengers so the first reaction was
mechanical failure
I think given all we do know and given
all the evidence we have a theory like
yours which nobody can disprove is is
you know it doesn't stand up very much
you know but you know I'm not gonna
change your mind if you know or
anybody's mind who wants to believe it
but I don't think the conspiracy theory
can hold up here is there any way that
this could have been on any type of a
spy mission yeah sure I mean could that
had cameras in it no no it didn't have
cameras in it they would have had
enormous two cameras or any kind of
equipment would have taken up weight
they would have been seen nobody in the
ground crew there was no attempt to
shield the plane either in New York or
Anchorage from ground crew inspection
they loaded the luggage ordinarily to
have done something like that would have
been a conspiracy of such a magnitude
you know that you're evolving you know
all the people that handled the ground
all the people that handle the
the baggage anybody else would be on the
ground ground-level walking by the plane
could see you no special equipment no I
don't think I also would have been
enormous weight additional weight on the
plane that didn't show up in any of the
manifest the logs also what are you
spying for in the olden days we used to
send aircraft right to the Soviet border
to activate radar so we could find out
where the Soviets radar was obviously
this was important to the Strategic Air
Command the American Strategic Air
Command in the Cold War the 50s and
early 60s because we were gonna send
bombers with nuclear nuclear weapons
into Soviet Union at any point we had to
know where they were strong and where
they were weak but once you get
satellites satellites were up there you
know whizzing around we have satellites
to go ferret satellites that go around
the Soviet Union that do make go around
the world every 93 or 96 minutes and
constant coverage every time a Soviet
radar activates we can copy it so we
know what the capability is we don't
need airplanes to do that anymore
Tenafly New Jersey or next you'll be TV
on in the background we're getting a
little feedback here who saw him on the
way into Anchorage visual contact knew
the pilot tried to raise him couldn't
raise him on any of these three radio
systems we had another salient point is
it not so that this guidance system the
INF has three separate keyboards to
function you have to do it three times
and your advanced theory is is that one
digit was pressed three times wrong
that's pretty extraordinary odds a third
point what altitude does in fact the
rc-135 fly at it is very low is it
doctor
okay good questions I'm glad you asked
all of them first as for the first one
about some radio report that the pilot
was unable to be raised I've never heard
of that report and I've read everything
carefully I'm not saying it wrong I'm
just saying that I I don't know about
and and it wasn't published
unfortunately and I've also gotten from
the networks all three networks
everything they put out on the on the
incident and it wasn't it wasn't carried
by either CBS NBC or ABC network it
could have been a local report
I just can't comment on it but there's
no such report I know of secondly there
certainly are what there isn't a
conflict to prevent the kind of error
that we're talking about in a 747 copic
there are three AI NS systems and three
separate keyboards one for the captain
which is generally the number one system
which flies the plane backups for the
co-pilot and backups for the flight
engineer and the idea is to get
redundancy to avoid the only time this
system is vulnerable is that as it is in
putting in the digits after that it's
fine if you put everything in right it's
going to go right it doesn't malfunction
occasionally it does but that's so where
I think 21 instances in in in about ten
years of flying it so where you can't
worry about it what happens is and by
the way all three systems under the
guidebooks or rule books of kaal and
most airlines all three systems are to
be loaded by the flight engineer
separately he's to go in at 30 minutes
before flight time and load them up
separately what happens all the time
is this the flight engine it's a hundred
digits he has to put in he has to first
put in the position you know longitude
and latitude where the plane is and by
the way if it's at gate k2 it's a
different position the gate k3 the
machine is that sensitive and so he
asked the log oven carefully and then
what he does is when he gets one in he
presses a button and remote loads the
other two that's happens all the time no
matter how many times airliners and
training crews work caution people not
to do it they do it it's just easier
it's quicker it saves twenty minutes and
you have to understand something this
crew had made the trip collectively
between all three of them a hundred and
seventy nine times between Anchorage and
the Far East
without any trouble I guarantee you the
first dozen times that flight engineer
did it he probably logged him in right
or the copilot somebody looked and after
that you know and what happens it's part
of the flying by rope again I can't tell
you this happened I can just tell you
what has happened I can tell you there
have been problems with KL
that they attributed to what they call
finger trouble that it's a problem that
does exist and it's known this kind of
remote loading the third thing is that
rc-135s fly not only slower but lower
than commercial airliners our
intelligence planes fly at a level about
29,000 feet over the Pacific and the
Comal ball and rivet joint most of the
commercial traffic airliners fly at
33,000 feet that's for obvious reasons
you want that separation in case
somebody gets lost they don't run into
each other they also fly oh how about a
certainly 50 to 100 miles faster then
the then the military planes the
military planes simply have a max the
707 flight a little little slower
however the Soviet radars are known the
codename for the Soviet Raiders that
operate in the Far East
they're the NATO code name is tall King
and the talking system human the talking
system is simply known by anybody in the
American Air Force and the American
intelligence business is to not be as
good of a system as we have in other
words it doesn't differentiate as well
it's not as good in height it's not as
good in size it's not as good on speed
it's far less precise so what you have
is a is a less sophisticated radar
device that can't track as carefully the
margin of error is as much as six eight
ten thousand feet I mean as six to eight
thousand feet even at even a thirty-five
thousand so you have a big margin of
error you can't be sure where they are
and the other the other point to be made
is for example the airliner had lights
on and somebody could call it and say
look the pilots chasing it he knows it
has lights on you know it you know looks
like it and why doesn't he do something
well the answer is once he's told it to
come a military plane lights on is
simply another way the plane is trying
to disguise itself you know there's an
answer to everything so I think there
your questions are well taken but I
think also the the answers aren't
inconsistent with any theory theory that
it was a total accident one of the
things you mention in the book was that
the Soviet pilot that supposedly
identified the plane was flying about
3,000 feet below the airliner and
although a 747 is easily identifiable
looking at it straight ahead from
looking underneath it might not be well
it's more important than that what
happened is when when we intercepted our
NSA people in the field in Japan
northern Japan intercepted we were
monitoring the Soviets as they chased
the plane in real-time and at one point
we heard the pilot says a boost coal
which is Soviet for missiles been fired
and then we also heard him say that the
title of my book the target is destroyed
the people there went bananas obviously
this is not a neck they initially
thought they were monitoring an exercise
this clearly isn't an exercise as luck
would have it the base of which they
were monitoring from and overheard it
from the American base was a very secret
base that was disguised not only for
general purposes but also from the
Japanese we didn't want the Japanese
this was in northern Japan northern
Japan is known as Project cleft there
was a little base we hadn't told the
Japanese about operating undercover with
Americans and civilian clothes blue
jeans so they didn't have a direct line
of communication because if they had
some communication line that Japanese
would have seen it heard what they had
as a regular series of pickups by
airliner by aircraft from the largest
the next nearest American base sort of a
mother base for the Far East and
intelligence was at Misawa Air Base
about 300 miles to the south and
northern Japan they called Misawa a pay
telephone no less and said we've got
something hot they weren't you know this
day and age you don't get that much hot
stuff up there things are tense but calm
Misawa had a fly a plane up pick it up
and fly it back
we weren't reporting what happened to
about four or five hours after the
incident in other words we collected it
in real time but we didn't we didn't
know what was going on when we first
began to send excerpts of the intercepts
to Washington one of the first
intercepts had the pilot saying I am a
beam of the plane and the CIA bill Casey
and a lot of people at Pentagon jumped
on that they thought that was clear
evidence that he was right there despite
the fact they were being warned all
night by the NSA to be careful with
these translations they chanced one
thing you know in the NSA business
whatever you get the first day never
holds up it's always changes
dramatically despite that they went
public one of my complaints is
Washington went public I think in the
beginning innocently and stupidly but
innocently I think George Schultz really
believed what he said he just
wrong and didn't correct the record for
which I hold him responsible but he went
public and said the pilot saw the plane
it turned out that he was B was a being
but 3,000 feet below and what Air Force
intelligence did that night again
it's an air incident and the Air Force
American air force is totally we monitor
when we have planes doing those
intelligence missions I'm talking about
River Joint Cobra Bal they are being
monitored all the time to make sure
they're safe that's one of the rules and
so when a plane gets shot down the Air
Force intelligence apparatus really
worked it they had a brand-new general
chief of Air Force intelligence named
General Jim foul it's a very fine
officer he had his troops really humping
they came in all night and one of the
things one of the bright guys did in
Washington is he called one of the
tanker pilots who refuel cobra ball and
rivet joint River joint stay up there so
long they have to be refueled at him
from air and he said tell me about
what's it like and the guy said from
underneath will you come up to refuel he
a couple pilots told him that we have
gone right to the belly of a Northwest
orient 747 or Japanese airline 747 and
try to put some fuel in them and realize
hey this isn't our rc-135 from the
bottom the lights are such you can't
tell the difference so this guy the
Soviet partly we know was operating
below and you know it's one of the
things to learn about this of course is
the Russian said there's nothing nothing
I said should take away the fact the
Russians did a horrible act they shot
down a plane without identified in
violation of their own rules they
panicked they grabbed their next they
clutched out nothing could diminish that
the right thing we should have done says
the American intelligence people with
whom I talk recommended that we simply
say we have intelligence the Soviet of
shot down an airliner in cold blood over
the over sakhalin island we hope they
have an explanation for this you know
boom the Russians would have been
massacred right instead we had to make
it a US Soviet event and say what we
didn't have evidence for that they had
identified it before shooting it down as
an airliner and said we hyped it and
then we continued to hide but it look it
played well one of the things you learn
about politics is if you got something
going you being the Russians up and was
a tense time in don't you remember we
wanted to get our Pershing two missiles
into Europe this made us a winner and
that whole
that'll there was they were expecting
great anti-war dissent and they didn't
get it anyway we'll go back to the
phones
see I'm Washington you're next yes I had
a conversation with Pan Am pilot flies
the Pacific and he was saying that the
Korean air pilots were giving bonuses
for saving fuel is there anything to
that and did you sure one of the things
we know about the Korean air pilots is
that Korean air runs a cut-rate airline
I think they probably were getting
bonuses for saving fuel and that's one
of the important ingredients in the
scenario that what I've done it in the
book has described the intelligent stuff
and and do my complaining about the way
they've manipulated the intelligence and
then also at the end I try and describe
what could have happened to the plane
I'm not pretending this is what happened
I'm just describing a moment-by-moment
what could have happened there is a way
that this plane could have gotten off
course and in such a way that and and
the pilot would not have known they
wouldn't have been the warning signals
will not have worked and it begins with
this thesis that what happens is some of
your pilots in the audience would know
what I'm talking about
once he gets in the air he's
automatically cleared by air traffic
control it's midnight in Anchorage
there's nothing up there he's given a
clearance for three four hundred miles
down the road the first thing he does is
he tries to look to see if there's a way
to cut a corner it's not unnatural to do
so he what he does is he does change his
route slightly once he's up there he
looks around checks the wind conditions
and finds a different point to go to in
an attempt to cut a corner maybe save a
couple of minutes and a little bit of
fuel and if he does that he done then
changes his course this is the captain
and once he does that then it's possible
that all sorts of other things can
happen particularly if in going to a new
course he screws it up he doesn't set it
right it's a scenario but it the the
guts of the scenario is that the pilot
once up there would have tried to get a
more efficient route that he was
initially given you know the routes
these guys get on these flights a
computer printout routes in fact
American Continental Airlines does is
responsible for giving Korean Airlines
its flight plan it's all computerized
but in reality the winds are a little
different once you get up there
and the weather conditions are a little
different and you can get up there and
if you're as smart the pilot was a
terrific pilot the chief pilot was one
of the better pilots and in Korean
Airlines and one of the things he would
do being an aggressive pilot would be to
try away to cut a corner he would never
never try and get himself closer to the
Soviet Union to save some fuel he's not
about to commit murder because one thing
you know is if you get into the Soviet
Union they're gonna shoot you down so
that I don't think he was reckless in
that regard he tried to make his corner
cutting getting out of Anchorage in the
first hour of flight that's probably
what happened you're absolutely right
one of the things you mentioned here in
the book is the Soviet Air Defense Force
was known to have repeatedly made
identification errors in the past and in
fact mistakenly authorized the
destruction of a Soviet passenger
airliner or several so V passenger
airliners with heavy loss of life
where'd you learn that well you got you
picked a sensitive spot because one of
the things I did in this book was
obviously I worked closely with people
in our intelligence community who wanted
to the Soviet Union and what I'm I I can
tell you that's something that I didn't
write as much about as I know on grounds
that how we know exactly what happens
the way we collect some of that
intelligence probably should not be
disseminated I could just tell you this
that we know that they've shot down
their own passenger planes by mistake
not knowing that it was a passenger
plane and now the Soviet Union has put a
special kind of gear known as a
transponder on all of its military and
civilian airliners commercial planes and
military planes so that the pilots of an
interceptor can do what they call an
interrogation may interrogate the
suspect plane and if it is a Soviet one
he can activate certain electronic
equipment that will give him a response
that says positive and ironically and
interestingly the plane that shot down
over seven we know that about five or
seven minutes before shooting it down he
did interrogate the plane I mean he
obviously may have had some doubt or
maybe that was just procedure
we really you know one of the things is
we don't know so much all we have is two
pilots conversation we don't know what
the Garonne control told him we were not
in a position intercept it next calls
from a State College Pennsylvania you're
on
yes mr. Hirsh oh and I certainly thank
you for bringing an awful lot of light
to this very very confusing subject
there were a few points though that that
I think might might even add a little
more to it number one I am absolutely
certain from my little knowledge of the
Russian air surveillance doctrine that
they would as a matter of course know
the route of all scheduled aircraft that
would pass through their space in fact
all surveillance systems do this and
should a severe I schedule aircraft not
make it make it a normal route they
would be very very much concerned with
that and be looking for it so the fact
this is not really a situation of a
Korean airline just popping out there
this is something that was happening all
the time in fact one of the ways that
you eliminate a lot of the work in air
surveillance is by making sure you know
the routine thing so that you can fairly
well discount them and put your efforts
on more important things the the second
thing let me do the first first okay no
I'll come back to you just so we don't
lose you want let me answer that
question first before you do your second
question okay let me just say quickly
that this plane was flying in uncharted
waters or air this was way off course it
was off the intended route and your
assumption that as a matter of course
would know the route of all scheduled
airlines and when something was delayed
they would be aware of it that makes a
lot of sense sounds good but now you
just start thinking of the fact that in
this air in this company country right
now we're in a position where what 30%
of all scheduled flights are delayed I
mean they would be going crazy if they
tried to keep to keep track with all
with all of the scheduled flights
because so many of them are delayed half
a day there's are those that I just
don't I think your assumption is that is
basically it can't work because they
certainly know where our air traffic
runs and where they're supposed to run I
could tell you right now they don't know
where each airliner is
don't write each one because they go out
of their mind just like any of us who
fly goes out of our minds right now I
mean trying to keep track of Airlines
they just know that they run here and
that anything that's here isn't supposed
to be here and is an intruder and an
enemy otherwise go ahead well we did out
of out of Jamia in the Far East until 75
when we stopped doing it because it
became very difficult we closed on a big
station we had there simply because when
you've got aircraft flying to your space
the Soviet Union does remember these are
the great paranoids of the world but but
the planes aren't flying through their
space the commercial airliners flying 50
miles away from space find very very
close to their space and and Kent and
and Kent can be considered ok anyway
that's the one that's nice I really
think you might look into that the
number two thing is yes I hear you say
that
the Korean pilot can save a little bit
of money by cutting corners I would
suggest that maybe you get contact with
some people over in the airport's over
in Korea Sewell I can almost certainly
say that this is not the first time this
has happened and that the little bit of
money that the pilot gets by coming back
and saving money on his fuel is nothing
in comparison to what he can get in a
thicket under the cover if he comes back
with a lot of saving which he doesn't
report to the company this is not the
first time that this has happened this
is not the tenth time this has happened
and fact I think this is even border
remember one when Gary Powers was shot
down this is not the first time that the
Russians saw the u2 the first time that
they caught it you - well this was the
same thing with this thing that they
really shot this plane down outside
their own airspace I believe they were
so anxious to finally get one of these
guys are you suggesting that the Korean
airliners were flying across over
territory regularly well all I can say
to you sir is that I've talked to the
American intelligence people who worked
at area
and there's absolutely no basis for that
let me say something to you but I can't
don't talk to American codes people go
talk to some of the elementary Koreans
operating a school that's important well
let me say that that as far as that
you're probably right about one thing
that I have been told and again this is
a very serious allegation to make just
so casually but I have been told by
people and I have not independently
verified it and nor nor that I see it
was relevant that there is a boom that
they do there is a little side pocket
deal that often they will they will be
behind and selling fuel some of the
pilots on the road you know not
necessarily working through the company
but doing some side pockets deal I don't
know if that's true or not but I do know
that that any pilot who decides to fly
into the Soviet Union in an effort to
save fuel is committing suicide and
murder and I don't think they're into
that I don't think that I think the
Korean airline pilots for all her
skepticism about about what they were
doing in this particular flight were by
and large professional responsible
trying to do the best they could under
pressure to save money certainly like by
the way most of our airline pilots are
all under pressure there's a tremendous
amount of pressure particularly when
fuel costs went up so high to maximize
efficient that's why everybody wanted to
fly the same route our 20 the
northernmost route because of the better
wind conditions so there's nothing
atypical and I think that there's any
basis to think that they were New Mexico
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well they did twice scrambled the first
time they ran into this plane was off
Kamchatka Peninsula which is in the Far
East maybe you'll put up a map Jim right
anyway if we can find it somewhere in
the book there's a map
it's in the hair let me let's take a
second to do it the first place was in
the Far East and I think it's right here
it's worth doing here it is here
Kamchatka the plane flies out of a
Alaska here goes across the ocean the
North Pacific this is Kamchatka were at
first penetrates Soviet territory it
over flies goes back into international
water here this is the sea of a horse
gets called and then it flies over
Saqlain which is right above Japan where
it shot down the first time it's
scrambled is right what happens is the
Soviets I think as I said earlier the
Americans have routinely operated
flights that go 3035 miles off the coast
of the Soviet Union the Soviet [ __ ] up
this plane coming into their territory
on their radar 200 miles off the coast
they see this plane that they
automatically assume as an American
intelligence plane start flying towards
the coast on the normal rules with an
intruder they should have put an alert
up and sent planes but they did not for
a simple reason this is I'm not telling
I think that's my speculation this is
what the American intelligence community
concluded they did not because these
guys come 230 miles and then they turn
they go along the coast that's what they
do all the time for 25 years he hits 30
miles and he keeps on coming panic in
the in the in the in the regional
coastal area of the Soviet Union for
airplane has scrambled to look at
intercept it shoot it down I don't know
what we know NSA knows that they were
given the wrong coordinates by what
radar facility they were sent to the
wrong spot in the sky by the time they
finally to untracked themselves I mean
we're talking about Katzenjammer kids
stuff by the find the time they finally
get untracked this plane is over the
land and going into international waters
they get on his tail but they chase him
out he's into international water they
let him go
there is no evidence that the people the
Soviet officials at Kamchatka told
anybody anything about this
they had blown it they were in big
trouble and they just hoped he would hit
international water whoever he was and
bail out there was a way to get out
without going back over Soviet territory
I think they just took a dive he keeps
on going he gets the soxhlet another
scrambler goes up and they shoot him
down that's what happened we have just a
couple minutes left and we have one more
call Greenbelt Maryland if you can make
it quick okay
something that you say in there and you
said it today that I find very hard to
believe is that you say there wasn't a
conspiracy because people in the
intelligence community haven't told you
that there was a conspiracy I mean you
really think that the people who knew
about this would come out and tell it
was Porter about it
well and let me quickly get in my second
question the second question is the kind
of conspiracy theory that I believe in
it's not that this was on some kind of a
spy mission but just the tremendous
propaganda advantage of this I mean you
have to understand the mentality of
these people I mean you know now you
hear that the atomic bomb was dropped on
Hiroshima not to end the war but to you
know give a signal to the Russians is
the first act of the Cold War these are
people who playing with millions of
lives so he can't say do you really
think that they're gonna kill 250 people
look at the propaganda advantages for
this and all of Southeast Asia any
Korean ever going to say you know let's
have an unbiased look at both the United
States and the Soviet Union this was a
tremendous thing for America let me say
this about about part two the question
of whether why the bomb was dropped I
think everybody will most people agree
it was dropped to end the war in a hurry
whether it was a wise decision or not
and there certainly may have been an
additional factor which was having to do
with the Cold War the Soviet Union but
the basic reason I think was pretty
clear was the end of war fast that
doesn't mean there was a rational
decision the other part to make is that
you have to know that in my career I've
been a terrible critic of the government
I'm the guy who wrote the stories about
the me line massacre and the CA domestic
spying and I have tremendous contacts in
the intelligence community and over
years you develop some faith you know
there's a lot of integrity in the
American military the intelligence
system they're a lot more than a lot of
people want to think everybody likes to
do their job right and what happens here
is that there were people that's so
appalled that this gets to your point
really the way the Reagan administration
manipulated the intelligence to beat up
the Russians after the fact the way they
did not tell the American people that
hey and the world that the Russians
really did nothing more than they did a
terrible thing but there's a difference
is he murder in manslaughter that
bothered the people in the intelligence
community and those same people who took
enormous chances that tell me
when they say there was no conspiracy I
simply believed him
I'm sorry we're gonna have to interrupt
here we're out of time the book the
target is destroyed what happened to
flight double-oh-seven and what America
knew about it Seymour Hersh Random House
thank you very much for being here thank
you very much for having me
thank you for your calls
[Music]
[Music]
if you'd like more information about
this or any other c-span program please
feel free to write to us our des is 400
North Capitol Street Northwest
Washington DC 2 0 0 0 1
[Music]